yeah been looking forward to this
thank you yeah my brother's taxing these
in the hospital you just got a rubber
bullet to the face he doesn't know if
he's gonna be able to save do you see
that that uh everyone's a pedophile
hashtag trending no what is that I don't
know why job made me share it oh my god
knows that the guy that got beheaded in
Soho yeah a little on fire and then they
used it as a battering ram to get into
Bloomingdale's it's nice to finally get
out there and make some change you know
yeah shake in here is it yeah you have
to get a dislike stuffed with truffles
or some you know your arteries
are on the way and I don't want to alarm
anyone but the first floor of the
restaurant has been commandeered by
protesters and is being used as a space
for organizing in addition part of the
restaurant is currently on fire and I
have been tested positive for covin 19
again not to worry your food is still on
the way and your new server will be out
with you shortly okay thank you so much
thank you thank you so much this place
is good yeah I told you are you dating
anybody
I mean to unhinge